There is a stunning and hilarious and pathetic
and disturbing new report from The New York
Times about Donald Trump threatening Mike
Pence with designating him as a pussy.
And that is a quote that is that his presidential
speech here, Mike Pence and Donald Trump had
a falling out, unlike any that I recall seeing
between a president and Vice President Donald
Trump.
We knew in the days leading up to the January
6th, counting of the electoral votes and what
became a riotous insurrection in Washington,
D.C., had been pressuring Mike Pence to do
it, do it, take steal the election, figure
out a way to do the right thing.
And we have actually now learned that Donald
Trump specifically said to Mike Pence in the
lead up to that day early last week, quote,
You can either go down in history as a patriot.
Wait for it or you can go down in history
as a pussy, of course, Mike Pence, Mike Pence
is a dangerous ideologue, extremist, but he
realized I can't steal the election there.
I don't have the power to steal the election.
Even if I wanted to steal the election, I
couldn't do it.
And very quickly, as it became clear Mike
Pence was not going to stand in the way and
as the riotous insurrection grew on Wednesday
afternoon, Donald Trump took to Twitter before
Twitter banned him and said Mike Pence couldn't
do it.
Mike Pence couldn't do it.
They then went up until Monday without even
speaking, despite the fact that Mike Pence
was put in physical danger at the Capitol
by the riotous insurrection that Donald Trump
incited.
And they reportedly had what is being sort
of, I don't even know, vaguely described as
a productive meeting on Monday.
Unclear what the relationship is between the
two of them.
So there's a few different things going on
here.
One of the things we have to be really careful
about and we talk about reputation is framing
normal behavior as heroic or virtuous, because
in comparison, so many people have been behaving
like absolute lunatics.
And what I mean by that is Lindsey Graham
is an example.
We talked about this earlier in the week.
Lindsey Graham on very late Wednesday, early
Thursday morning, last week, spoke during
the counting of the electoral vote.
And he said things that are just the way it
is.
Lindsey Graham said, our duty is just to count
the votes.
Some of these objections are out of scope
for the House and Senate in a joint session
to really even deal with things, went to courts
and courts, made decisions.
And he was held up as a hero for like six
hours.
Until then, he said insane things the next
morning and then also the following night
on Fox News.
And one of the problems is that we talk about
the Overton Window and the value of pulling
the Overton Window to the left, for example,
to bring the center to the left to mainstream
progressive ideas.
But there's another Overton Window that's
been absolutely brutalized during the last
four years, and it relates to hyper normalization
when you have a two month campaign from veritable
lunatics like Donald Trump and Rudy Giuliani
and Sidney Powell and Josh Holly and Lin Wood
and you know, the full list of these people
to insist without evidence the election was
stolen, stolen this that.
The other thing when somebody simply says.
This goes beyond the limits of what we are
allowed to do based on our appointments here
in the House and Senate, they seem so reasonable
and people start saying these are the good
Republicans.
No, Lindsey was on TV the next night begging
for mercy for Trump and saying impeachment
would be divisive.
Well, then he should have thought of that
when he did something worthy of impeachment.
That would have been the time to think about
it before it became too late.
So let's we're ending Donald Trump's term
with something very similar to what I said
at the beginning of Donald Trump's term, which
is we must work hard.
And it's really tough to avoid the hyper normalization
when so much of what we see daily is outrageous,
when what we see every week would have been
a one year scandal for Barack Obama had it
happened, then it's very difficult not to
see been this slightly less cartoonish, but
still not benign right wing radicals as being
sort of sensible.
And, you know, when we say Mitt Romney actually
seems to be making some sense, we're not saying
we agree with him politically.
At least I'm not we're not saying he's a friend
of progressives.
We're simply saying he has been consistent
on what are the limits of the House and Senate
and presidential power, et cetera.
I still disagree with him on tax policy.
I still disagree with him on a whole bunch
of other things.
But at least he's been consistent.
Lindsey Graham is not that Mike Pence is not
that Mike Pence was limited not by his delusions
of grandeur.
We don't know what he might have wanted to
do.
Could he have gotten away with it?
He was limited by the fact that he can't actually
do the thing Donald Trump was asking him to
do.
And it's a very important thing to remember
as we get past this administration and it
gets into the rearview mirror and we think
about it, we want to remember it for what
it was.
It was hard to fight the normalization while
it was going on.
And we have to remember that we're going to
have to work just as hard to fight it in retrospect
and really remember just how insane it was.
We will ultimately see what happens with impeachment
in the Senate.
But the it it is at the same time extraordinary
that a president denounced his own vice president.
But Mike Pence deserves no praise for not
doing the thing Trump asked them to do because
in the end, he couldn't do it.
It simply is not something that he could do.
Make sure you're following us on Facebook,
at Facebook, dotcom slash The David Pakman
Show.
We will take a quick break and be back with
much more right after this.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.